this is the aftermath of torrential
rains that have hit Northeastern Kenya
in the last few
days towns and Villages are flooded
scores of people have lost their homes
many have moved to Higher Ground the
rain is still pounding and they could
soon be forced to move again flood
waters across the country have killed
more than a dozen
people this water has affected us our
houses have been down damaged our crops
have been washed away our livestock is
gone scientists say climate change is
causing more intense and frequent
extreme weather the region is coming out
of its worst drought in 40 years
thousands of people livestock and
Wildlife have died during four failed
rain season there's an urgent need for
humanitarian support because there are
displacement there are areas which are
cut off and this is a rain that you know
has
all over the the
region people in neighboring Somalia
have also died about 300,000 are
estimated to have fled their homes
Ethiopia and Uganda have recorded
unusually heavy rains some experts say
these are effect of the El Nino weather
phenomenon created as Seas war and
people should brace themselves for more
rain Katherine soy Al jazer
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer